president zielenski called and londoners
answered we
stand with the people of ukraine
thousands of them showing support for
ukraine and marking a month since
russia's invasion
london's mayor says the capital has a
long history of giving refuge to those
fleeing conflict there's a disconnect
between the generosity shown by
londoners and brits across the country
and the actions of our government and
what i compare and contrast what we as a
country have done from our government
versus those i'm embarrassed
the march weaved through the city's
landmarks yoko ono's message of peace on
piccadilly circus
and trafalgar square dressed in
ukrainian colours in the days after the
government launched the scheme to give
refuge to those fleeing the conflict
more than 140 000 people signed up to
house a refugee in their own homes
it's here at this protest many of the
people we've spoken to say they want to
help keep it going
either because of a shortage of space or
because they don't trust the government
system
trouble is we don't live in a house
that's really quite big enough as far as
we can tell if i did it
and after six months
i have no faith that they would have
anywhere to go and i wouldn't be able to
throw them out and
and i just can see too many
complications i feel so sorry for these
people who
have been through unimaginable trauma
and then come across british bureaucracy
when they're trying to get here i think
it's absolutely disgraceful
on the ground in ukraine britain's
support is getting noticed
people are having these jokes that
before shooting for granted launcher
people are saying save the queen and
then they're hitting the the armored
russian armor so everything is here the
financial assistance political
assistance military and humanitarian
that's why it's so important to have
this event right now right here
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow plans for another rally which
president zielenski himself is set to
address
thousands more are expected there saudia
chaudhary sky news in london